[Music]
you were just in Russia never been to
Russia and I have to know what's it like
what's it like to be there it was pretty
tricky really it's cold and dark and
people are not good-looking I feel bad
but it was it was like it the men were
all bald and smoking and the women the
pretty ones are here I think it was
rough I had like they get out of Russia
and they come here you know how people
think Russian women are pretty like
Russians I'm like no the ones that are
good are over to here so it was hard it
was really cold and it was really gray
and it was like I had like Pro tea the
food is awful so I ate like protein bars
and vodka for like four days I thought
that was your diet anyway I always got
the protein bars
yeah but the food is it was bad I mean
you know I went there because I want to
have an interesting you're going to
aren't you going somewhere oh no no I am
I just said I'm going to South Korea
okay because we were gonna go to South
Korea and then we found out you're going
so now we can't go why can't you go to I
don't know why should both of us go it
was South Korea just one of the plays I
felt like if they could they might take
me you know like I would be the type of
loud American that they'd be like Putin
would be like we'll just take her and
put her away like capture me you know
well this is interesting because you
sort of were asking for trouble you
tweeted at Vladimir Putin that you
wanted to go horseback riding with him I
didn't you yeah and you do I know did
you hear back from him no because he's a
[Applause]
you say it now that you're back here
right well I love their tweet you sent
out look at this this is you let's get
in I don't know if you can see you
wanted to go with him and so you sent
him that picture of you bare bare
chested I'm just gonna say bare chested
okay yeah that was me yeah that's you I
said I am I will say it now I mean he
yes I was scared while I was there I
wasn't scared enough to because I did
want to go horseback riding with him I
would like to do something with him talk
to him and see how crazy he really is
but now that I'm home and safe I feel
fine you went down to the subways
they're very proud of their subways they
have these like mosaics and the ceilings
of their subways that they call their
Taj Mahal not great either I mean I
don't want mean obviously Netflix is
you're a great ambassador to other
countries good what is that screaming in
with blows Netflix is screaming in
Russia people are like shut her up
already but yeah don't go okay
there were so many other places to go
you know what I mean there's so many
places to see so I mean I'd rather go to
India you know get diarrhea for a week
then go back to Russia I'm sure you'll
be welcome there now they can't wait for
you now all right yeah is there anyone
you haven't what hemisphere haven't you
alienated yet I don't know I don't know
it's hard tricky because you know
Netflix is on in so many different
countries I have to be a bit more
careful with what comes out of my mouth
so I'm just gonna stop
[Laughter]